[Music]
celebrity income breakdown for example
you'll see what I'm talking about a Ted
Cruz we looked into it we found out that
60% of his income is senatorial salary
10 percent comes from publishing
advances and 30 percent residuals for
being the tragedy man famous
tragedy master that's him Wow he gets
yeah yeah Abdel we looked into Adele
Adele makes 1 percent from concert
tickets
she makes 1 percent from merchandising
and she makes 98 percent churning her
drunk voice mails into number 1 Steve
Buscemi the great actor Steve Buscemi
80% of his money's from acting roles 15
percent of his money's from foreign
commercials 5 percent is from selling
old contact lenses to be used as biodome
george w bush we looked into it 50
percent of his money comes from speaking
fees 50% from autobiography royalties
and 50% side job as Texas math teacher
to get Paul I'm retired right Kid Rock I
looked into this oh I knew America wants
to know why where's Kid Rock's money
come right sure because that's a
question we all ask ourselves Kid Rock
sixty percent is digital downloads
twenty percent of his money comes from
touring and twenty percent from Etsy
sales of rocks sobs let's be honest no
one understood what that one was
I'm not sure I understand oh I
understand is he knitting socks that
don't is that what he's doing
yes Coenen that's what he's doing
thanks Andy Oh brah Blaine how it works
and now you've spoiled your Christmas
present
wonders not but it's not that much yarn
in the world I just like I just like
that I somehow got your measurements
yeah
color and I need a measurement of your
penis do you mind no reason yeah that's
why you asked me to lie down nude on
that wet slab of ruddy nothing for this
hey Bill Nye the Science Guy where's
that guys plans coming from sure woo him
whatever Bill Nye the Science Guy
99% comes from science 1% from guy
though dr. ron perlman people love that
actor he's an intense guy right look at
this thirty per six thirty six percent
of his money comes from residuals from
sons of anarchy
twenty nine percent of his money comes
from other acting roles 35 percent
modeling work for national salon chain i
know he's a great actor but look big
cuts you're now you're guaranteed to
running i'm gonna run into him tomorrow
yeah tomorrow it cuts a whammo I tried
to tell him run I'll just be a red wig
on life support Ben Carson ben Carson
yeah check this out fifty-five percent
of his income comes from surgeons salary
fifteen percent from book sales and 30
percent mass cut for sleepy time kylie
jenner yeah we looked it up twenty six
percent of our money comes from tweeting
photos of lips twenty six percent comes
from tweeting photos of but forty eight
percent compound interest from small cap
mutual fund investment Wow yeah
very wise industrial high yeah didn't
see that one coming did you we gave you
the old slipper ruled Steven Tyler
that's right
fifty percent money comes from music
sales 20 percent touring and public
appearances
30 percent scaring crows in a field and
finally Nick Cannon we looked into it
100% Mariah Carey
hey thanks for watching be sure to click
subscribe to see even more great Conan
clips you may now return to your pirated
movies and creepy Japanese pornography